[Plays MATT OX - Overwhelming (Prod. OogieMane)]
The fuck is this gay shit?
NO
NO!
Ahhh!
Ohhh!
HELL YEAH!!!!
*Hitmarker*
AHHHHHH!
I almost DIEEEEEEED
Alright
So
We sold out all the hoodies (Good)
But (Nani!?)
I know you guys like Fidget Spinners
So now you can buy your
Official
Purderpie
Fidget Spinners
You ain't spun, until you spun this shit boi
Right
Okay let's get started with this video
Uh-
Lemme just-
hah
*Jogs over to pink chair gracefully*
Wa-Was that cool?
*Shouts* Was that cool?!?! I don't know if you can hear me!!!! (Oh we can hear you alright Felix)
CONTEXT!
DOESN'T MATTER!
Everyone knows this!
It's been proven!
Many times!
That context doesn't have any effect
what-so-ever!
I know what you're thinking "Phh! Pewdiepie, context matters a great deal! Otherwise...
*Burps* (Ten outta ten)
Everyone is just, eh, can be whatever-
THEY WANNA BE!!!
Context matters
Poodiepie
Because otherwise, you can twist anyone's narrative to make them look however you like!"
I know!
But this is a false statement
I'll prove it to you
Just look at anime
*Reading* "Everyone, Satan just called"
Don't need to know the context of this
What I do want to know is why her eyes are so
*laughs* fucked up
And what anime this is
Because it seems like, an excellent anime
Is it Dragon- Its Dragon Ball!
I- I do remember that one time where Satan called!
*Soundboard effect*
"DISAPPOINTEEEEEDDDD"
Well that was fitting
And more anime examples
of where that context doesn't matter
*Reading* "I'm not giving up, no matter how big it is" (That's what she Said)
I don't see a- I don't see a problem with that
W-What's weird ABOUT THAT?
NEVER GIVE UP!
There's some more examples of anime
*Misreads* "I'll put it out when it matters"
*Mumbles* I'll put it- I'll pull-
I'll PULL It out when it matters!
*laughs* (Goddamnit Pewds)
*In a deep voice* Now that's some gay shit my man
What the fuck is that? *laughs*
I knew Fullmetal Alchemist was
some gay ass anime but- (that's not FA that's Charlotte)
*Deep voice* This is some weird shit man
what the fuck?
There's also context in- for streamers
You know you- you're spending all day talking
There's no way anything that
you say can be taken out of context
Let me prove it to you!
*MissBaffy on stream*
"Literally a four year old I was babysitting
I was like- I was like fucking his ass but then I felt bad"
MOVING ON!
OKAAAAAY
*Reads thread title* "Anyone else try the Hal- Marlboro edge yet? They just came out- here."
Ok. Nothing wrong with that,
uh, one of the comments says
*reads comment* "I read online that they were going to be slims and I was super excited about them...
Now that's a little gay,
*reads the rest* I was extremely disappointed both that they weren't slim
Uh- "and that they have the same weird, dirty taste that all other Black's have"
*Making "well that aint good" noices*
We all know about that DIRTY TASTE!
Another- another uh- typical Reddit racism
*reads comment* "I had an HP laser (printer) at home that cost me about $400...
...I went through a grand total of 3 toner cartridges before we lost the printer
In a house fire
In 2016"
"Meanwhile, a cheap black Brother is like $75 now"
RA-SIS-M
That is extremely RA-SIS-M
I'm disgusted by this!
*reads screen again* "a cheap black Brother"
*To himself* Shit
Fuck
What do I do
Jävla helvete (Fucking hell)
Oops
You see here? Context. Doesn't. Matter. *laughs*
I keep telling you guys *hits desk* context *hits desk again* doesn't
MaaAATtEeRRr
Lets- Lets see some more examples
Here's a random shot of a couch (Thanks Felix. Just what we wanted)
*reads screen* "Cleaning up while your kids are awake is like wiping your ass...while there is still shit coming out"
*reads screen again* "There's a thin layer of toddler covering every surface of m-
OKAAAAYY!!!
OKAAAYYY!
*claps* OKAAYY
Context...still doesn't matter
I have discovered underwater rats
Eeh it still doesn't matter
*reads video title* "The best of Mr. Wizard"
Mr. Wizard was my- my favorite Nickelodeon show
Ehh, there's nothing you can take out of context from that beautiful man-
Boy: "That's a big hole!"
Mr. Wizard: "Yeah!
Certainly big enough to put around you"
*Pauses video and rethinks life for a second*
No
NOOOO!!!!
Mr. Wizard: "Now watch the size of this hole!
Will you come with me please?"
*laughs & chuckles*
Yes!
Mr. Wizard: "would you like to blow?"
Boy: "Nope! You can do it heh"
Oh my god! What the hell is this show?! What the hell? What the fuck is wrong with it?!?
Mr. Wizard: Here-
Boy: "Oh it's getting bigger!"
Mr. Wizard: "Yes!"
Mr. Wizard: "Run this up and down ten times,
and what do you think you're doing with this?"
*Boy starts rubbing it* 1, 2, 3-
What the fuck is this show?!
What the fuck is this show?!?
What the fu- *chuckle* -ck
*Smacks table*
Cartoons were way better back in the day!
I've been missing out man!
Hell yeah!
*Boy continues* "Uh, 6, 7-"
What the fu- what the fuck is this?
What the fuck is this?? What the faurhahagrch
Boy: "7, 8, 9, 10!"
No one?
No one saw a problem with-
with the 9 tips?
7, 8- no one saw the problem that?
No one behind the scenes were like-
- "Gee- hey maybe we shouldn't make the kids do this?"
Fuckin hell
Respect! I respect you producer!
Mr. Wizard: "One thing is that you get a
piece of wood that just slips inside just like that"
What the fuck? Why, what the he-
everything! everything!
No, no no no no no
no no no no no. Mr. Wizard: I'll show you.
Kid: help!  AHHhHh what the hell is this how come you can't suck it up
when you do it slowly? I don't know. okay
well I'm through with you you'll be
sorry you said what you said then when
we've exhausted you and you can't suck
anymore, down it comes here you want to
play with us? Sure! all yours (damn he naughty)
Do you mind if I do the acid? No. Felix: This man has
no context does not exist in this man's
universe god bless you Mr. Wizard
god bless yourself cuz god damn
[That's how much I have to blow?]
okay alright I always wondered how much do I have to blow.
See that little bead
of surface tension up there? YEEEEEAAAHHHH-HA-HA-HA-He...
It broke. (No shit Sherlock)
yeah, great tease, over and ouuuut!
*Some sexy music*
God bless you mr. wizard. God bless your
soul a-a-and I keep- I keep telling you guys context
doesn't matTER!!!
AH it's so obvious! Have you opened your ass yet?
hey Edgar does context matters? - SHUT THE FUCK UP YOU CUNT!(Edgar's first words!!! awwww...)
Anyways so let's gooo and move on.
Context happens to everyone. Even Youtubers, your favorite one like Jackseptis- (How did you know!)
Jack: I normally don't make videos. I'm
making this video to ride a bandwagon,
because anti-semitism
*Cute chuckle*
See I told you. It
doesn't matTER!
Out of context. I know Felix like very well in my personal life
and I know for a fact that he's an
anti-semitic person.
I'm just trying to
like for the people who are asking is he
a Nazi or not I'm trying to say
I'm monetizing this video (lol) *Felix busts into laughter*
hows to the Wall Street Journal who broke this story, I
don't think they're wrong to actually
break the story and I agree with them,
so I don't even know how to end this video...
Ummmmmm...
I normally don't make videos. (I lost all faith in Jack :( thanks Felix.)
*Weird ass chuckle* I told you
guys context doesn't matter it doesn't matter.
cause clearly this is how is
video was.
Now I asked you guys to prove
as well that context doesn't matter so
let's see what you guys sent me.
Seven and a half seven inches. (a penis can't get that long, sorry to burst your bubble.)
Eight or nine
inches long. (I JUST SAID IT CAN'T GET THAT LONG!)
Ten centimeters about four inches. (Now he knows what he wants.)
*Who chuckles like that?* Oh beautiful.
No! Fu- god damn it guys,
god damn it. See that's what I'm talking
about. The Turtles
I knew Michele Angelou was my favorite
turtle and I knew I picked a good man
of a turtle.
Hell yeah. This is just fucking weird I'm out of
context. I can't.
Hey you still have that tattoo by
the way man? (do you?)
*Pewds laughing like an idiot.* Heell yeah. *More Laughter*
I've been watching the wrong anime man! This is my
top number one anime.
Strange stuffs happens when things are taken out of
context. (What the hell? XD)
Ironic that this is that both Disney...(Stfu before Disney finds out you said that)
okay moving on
They just keep coming and coming and we
don't even know what they are. We
don't know anything. That's okay. WAT.
They-they-they know what they were doing with this
one, okay. Tentacles semen coming uuuuuuhh, I
need to start watching Stevan universe
Now, we had a great time talking about
context here today isn't that right mr.
Edgar-san? Hey! Wake the fuck up! Wake up!
Come on I need I need a comment.
I can't be taken out of context. (oh really?) I am literally
uncontestable that's the word right now
I just trade marked it. I'm un-uncontestable
look at my videos for example.
Jelly on my Sword. You Jelly? You Jelly? No! NO! My controller stopped working! Wait! Wait!
I hope you die. What. You came in my mouth! (wtf XD)
Like I said uncontestable!
Impossible there's no way you ain't got
nothing on me! They got him jack and
everyone else can't on context horizon me man.
I love this picture like what the
fuck is happening I don't even remember
This this is sad. This is normal
okay everyone does this. Every youtuber
ever does this. Ain't nothing out of
context about it. Ain't nothing out of
context. *Weird ass laugh, like wtf man* good job good job.
What else do you guys not all you got
let me see that I think there's going to
be a lot of eyes on me during this video
so I'm going to address this as if
anti-semitic but- Da for fuck sake! damnit. You may
have gone in my old videos but there
there's nothing you got on my older
stuff okay (that makes no sense)
ain't nothing that you can find a my old stuff!
Older pewdiepie. Haw's it goin bro's?!?!
No nO NO!! play please please stop
it stop it everyone just stop.
Alright this video was singing from @PDPIdeas
it's a Twitter account just dedicated to
give me ideas because I am NOT out of
ideas that is why.
Stop thanking me! You're disgusting! It that a- it that a transgender?
*Laughs at himself, egotistic much*
Okay ah. I really appreciate your guys help.
Making these videos when the times are tough not just
in the monetization but, the creativity
and the overall talent. I'm just go
to go to the nether realm and
I'll see you bros in the next video!!!! (Holy shit, where you going!!! I want to come too!)